(cris de rebelion)
(coup de fusil)
Cette étudiante de 20 ans,
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a ar
anonymement. Depuis la mort
en détention de Mahsa Amini,
comme bien des Iraniennes,
elle est descendue dans la rue.
(c
Comme ses concitoyennes,
Manal brave la répression.
♪ ♪ ♪
Elle puise son énergie dans
les paroles de cette chanson,
devenue virale, écrite par un
Un hymne à la révolte
et un appel à l'uon.
MAHNAZ SHIRALI, sociologue,
auteure et spécialiste de l'Iran
battues toutes seules contre
le régime, eeses n'ont jamais eu
enfin très peu, très peu de
soutien des hommes. Mais c'est
un soutien massif de la part
des mmmmes pour la cause
féminine.
- À Shiraz, cette autre lycéenne
de 18 ans, avec qui nous avons
échangés, ne se fait aucune
illusion sur son sort si jamais.
- Mais pour le gouvernement
iranien, cette duquququququququ.
Le ministre de l'éducation a
annoncé que s s détenues seront
placées dans des centres
psychiatriques.
- On les
Ce type de comportement, que
la République islamique est en
train de manifester envers
les opposants iraniens et lesese
siècle. On est au 21e siècle
et ils sont en train de se
comporter comme les régimes
moyenâgeux.
Manal a déjà eu affaire
à la lilice des moeurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais par-dessus tout, elle nous
confie qu'elle veut pouvoir
marcher dans la rue et sentir
sur son cou.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa